Lindsay Levin: We’ve just
heard from Maersk,
just one of the players
that you deal with.
Why is a center like yours needed?
Bo Cerup-Simonsen: Because we're looking
at a massive systemic change.
It’s huge, and it needs to happen fast.
No country, no company,
no matter how large and powerful,
can do this alone.
So collaboration is going to need
to be a part of the solution.
And our center is all about that.
It is all about collaborating
across the ecosystem,
across the value chain
in order to accelerate the transition.
What Maersk is doing
is absolutely exemplary,
but few companies have the resources
and have the courage
to do what Maersk is doing.
So you can say it's moving,
it's scaling too slowly, when you look
at the industry-wide perspective.
So what we really need to do
is to turn those first-mover activities,
those leading activities,
into industry-wide practices.
And so this is what
we're doing in our center,
this is what we're aiming to do.
And when the center was established,
about three years ago,
with a large philanthropic donation
from the A.P. Moller Foundation,
the basic idea was that we need to create
a completely new way
of collaborating across the ecosystem.
The basic idea was that we need
to establish an independent center
that would have no vested interest.
We need to collaborate with governments
and with companies across the globe,
across the ecosystem,
and we wanted to establish
a team co-located
so that economists and engineers and so on
would sit side by side
and imagine the future
and develop the solutions.
So this was the idea.
And of course there were a lot of concerns
about compliance and antitrust
and IP and confidentiality
and practicalities.
But we have found a model now,
we have overcome those challenges.
And now, today, we have more
than 100 organizations across the globe
joining the center.
Many are sending people to
our team in Copenhagen.
Competitors are sitting side by side
to develop the solutions of the future.
LL: So that's fabulous.
Give us a sense of where
and why we're still lagging.
BCS: Well, if you look three
or five years back,
I think we were lagging
on the technology side,
we were lagging on the commercial side,
we were lagging on the regulatory side.
But over just the past few years,
and you just saw
an amazing example of that,
we've seen tremendous development
in the space of technology.
So now, just over the next
one to two years,
we will see container ships,
like what you just saw,
we'll see tanker vessels,
big bulk carriers,
cruise ships, car carriers
being built and getting in the water,
running on new types of fuels.
For example, methanol, methane,
ammonia a little later.
So this is now all maturing,
and the technical readiness
level is really high.
So the big focus now
is on the commercial readiness,
on the upscaling opportunity
and the barriers for that.
And there, we're looking
at two categories of drivers
and also two areas
that we have to focus on.
And one is a purely market-driven one
where a customer demands a green product,
a car, for example, an electric vehicle,
and that has to be produced.
And that supply chain needs
to work in a green manner.
So that is driving now
a part of this transition.
As we just heard,
it's just that on the industry-wide scale,
it's not moving fast enough.
But then we have the regulatory side,
and here we've just had
a major breakthrough
in the International
Maritime Organization.
So just about a week ago,
all 175 countries came together.
They agreed.
We had Asia with China,
we had Europe, we had US, we had Africa.
Everybody agreed that we need
to update our strategy.
We need global regulation for shipping,
we will go to zero by around 2050,
we will use sound
technical measures to go there,
and we will use economic measures
like a carbon pricing.
So that is now a global framework
that has been agreed across the globe.
So it's a fabulous fundament
for moving forward from here.
LL: Yeah, so congratulations
to all of those involved in that.
(Applause)
What's still difficult
and what are the opportunities?
BCS: So it's still difficult going forward
because we're looking at a massive
change on a systemic level
and a massive change on individual level.
So a shipowner is looking
into an uncertain future.
It's much easier to quantify
the additional cost
and the additional risk
than it is to quantify
the additional opportunities
or the risk of not doing anything.
So that means a lot of companies
and a lot of countries
are stuck with this uncertainty
and are hesitant to move forward.
A ship owner will be hesitant
because she doesn't know
which fuel type to bet on
or if the customers will pay.
A country, for example,
a developing country, is hesitant
because it's concerned about increased
cost of imported goods
or how export competitiveness
will influence workplaces and so on.
So this is a lot of uncertainty in there.
And this is where we work as a center
to address all those uncertainties
and those risks and remove those
so that decision makers can move forward.
LL: So finally, give us an example
of a specific thing
that the center is doing to help affect
that kind of change.
BCS: So one of the great things,
or one of the things that we've had
a lot of interest in recently,
is to work with green corridors.
A green corridor is the realization
of that new business system.
So we work, for example,
a lot with the Chilean ministries
and we've worked a lot
with stakeholders in Chile
to understand how Chile
can produce renewable energy,
how they can turn that into fuels,
how they can retrofit their ports,
how ship-owning companies
can transport using green fuels,
and how, for example,
the Chilean mining industry
can transport copper
with zero carbon transportation
so that they can export green copper
that can be used in, for example,
electric vehicles in the future,
and thereby support the production
of these green supply chains.
So green corridor is really getting
all those stakeholders together
across the entire chain.
It is reimagining,
you can say, the future,
putting that new business system in place,
defining how that new business,
what it looks like.
And we are right now,
for example in Chile,
brought that all the way forward
to feasibility study.
So it's very concrete now.
And then we take that learning
and we turn it into a general blueprint
and we share that with the world
so that every region,
everybody can go in and use this cookbook
for how to develop a green corridor.
And I think this is our way of working.
We try to identify the decision makers
that can really make this move.
And then we work specifically
with those leaders, both on company level,
so this is typically at strategy,
leadership level,
or in country government level,
to understand what do they need
in order to move forward.
So in addition to the green corridors,
we've developed a number
of guidelines and services,
how a ship owner
should invest in new ships,
how a country should support
the development of future regulation, etc.
So this is our way of working.
LL: Fabulous, Bo, thank you very much
for the work that you're doing.
I know that there's going to be
a lot of people here in other industries
that want to learn from your example.
Thank you for being with us.
BCS: Thank you very much.
(Applause)